[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where ned
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
number one best-selling author of the
book paycheck to purpose and ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth do work that they love
and create amazing actual relationships
todd is with us todd is in mesa arizona
hi todd welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey ken huh
uh just calling up to uh
see if i should uh prolong
my
education to take advantage of my
employer's uh
tuition reimbursement program
the
total cost of this program is going to
be thirty thousand dollars
and but the the one caveat is my
employer they they only reimburse up to
ten thousand dollars a year
and i would
prefer to just rip this band-aid off and
get the the program done within two
years so that would be uh
fifteen thousand dollars a year
uh leaving me responsible to cover five
approximately
five thousand dollars um
do you have that cash on hand where you
could cover it
we do uh
currently uh my wife and i were were
saving up for a down payment on
hopefully our first home good what are
you studying
uh this is going to be a master's of
engineering for
mine engineering
what does it do to your income when you
get that
the roi on it would be pretty great
i think it would
pretty much boost it about 30 grand in
one year
that kind of answers the question don't
know
like if you got it a year sooner you get
the 30 grand a year sooner and you're
only paying 10 grand to do that yeah
yes it was you know wait a minute stop
stop but make sure i didn't miss
something okay
if you get it in two years
you get a 30 grand raise in the third
year that you wouldn't get uh into if
you hadn't finished right
okay yep and
to do that you have to come out of
pocket with 10 grand
five each year
yep which you have i'm trading 10 for
30.
good trade
i like it when you frame it like that
well just kind of being a cheap skate
yes but no
you're cutting your nose off spite your
face so buddy yeah and todd you're the
one that said just moments ago i want to
rip the band-aid off and get it done
and yeah and so the math supports your
desire so this is a no-brainer how big a
company is this
they're
multinational
uh mining giant okay
perfect
i know where this is going because you
know what they need
they need what you do
really bad
and you're a fairly rare bird
that that is true okay so what i'm gonna
do is walk into my supervisor and go
dude
you all need to up it yeah am i i need a
little waiver i need a little amendment
to the uh big corporate giant stupid
butt policy and you all need to pay 15 a
year for mine
uh that way i'm helping you at adding
value to your organization our
organization at a faster pace
um
and i'll even sign something that says
if i if i leave before the end of the
third year when you would have given me
the money anyway i'll pay it back yeah i
love that dave
i love her right because hey listen
that's not going to offend them
you have no risk in that conversation as
long as you keep that posture of just
hey here's an idea here's a thought
here's what the rules say i can knock
this out in two would you guys consider
that that's not going to be negative
even if they say well we're not going to
do it you're not going to hurt yourself
yeah but i mean they you know listen
just talk to your supervisor listen
how hard are you guys out there
recruiting people for this exact role
right now
and i'm willing to step into that role a
year sooner but i need a waiver
and i'm even willing to guarantee you a
zero risk on it because if i leave early
i would pay it back that's that's like
even you might even get corporate
america to think about that
dave i don't know that makes too much
sense yeah we're trying to get brain
cells to work here but yeah yeah that's
that's a cool thing either way you're
doing it
even if you come out of pocket with it
you're doing it that's correct because a
10 10 trading for 30 is a good trade
yeah this is i want to do it or i'm
going to regret you will regret it on
some level short term regret but why you
don't need to you got the money and
here's the other thing
you'll make up that 10 grand faster for
that house payment anyway dave just
played the math out for you so this
doesn't hurt the dream in any way of
buying the house yeah your instinct
towards the band-aid was the correct
instinct
and uh the neat thing about someone
that's got this much engineering under
their belt is that math is their second
language anyway so he already felt the
math he just hadn't done it the way i
did it
so you can they just it's down in the
dna it's swirling around he's going no
this is right i just can't figure out
why it's right so all right claire is
with us claire's in nashville hi claire
how are you
hi dave super excited to talk to you
today you too how can we help
yeah so i just accepted a job with a new
company and i'm very excited about it
but i did realize that this company
doesn't offer a 401k match they have a
401k
um just no match so my question for you
is
should i participate in this 401k or
should i just open up a roth ira what do
you think
well once you're out does the 401k offer
roth
um it's a traditional only
is that what you're saying
okay
no you would do a roth ira first here's
the math the math says take all the
match first you don't have that
roth is better than traditional so you
max out your roth
before you do any traditional and then
if that doesn't get you to your 15 in
baby step four
um then you would do some in traditional
but roth is better than traditional
match is better than roth
and so roth beats
i mean match beats roth beats
traditional and the best of all worlds
is a match with a roth obviously but you
don't have that so
uh and of course you're not doing any of
this if you're not at baby step four and
you don't have your emergency fund in
place and you're not debt-free other
than your house right
right i am already in baby step four
perfect you're rocking a girl i will add
to that my current employer now so this
is a new position i'm accepting but my
current employer i have been
contributing to the 401k with them
because they had a match so that should
just roll over into
another 401k no you'd i would just roll
it to a traditional
ira ira
and you pick some mutual funds so what
you need to do is you need to jump on
ramsey solutions.com click smart
investor pro find some of the folks
there in your area that we recommend for
investing we're not in the investing
business but these are people you're in
nashville it's probably the same people
i use you know and so um
you're gonna sit down get a roth ira
going and do a direct transfer
rollover to a traditional ira from the
old 401 k and you'll have no taxes on
that if you do the direct transfer
and that's what you should do so hey
good question congratulations on the new
job
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host we were just talking off air
about how excited are we are we're
leaving in the morning
to come to las vegas those of you in las
vegas we're doing a building wealth live
event tomorrow night the uh it's located
at central church there if you haven't
reserved your seats you can still get
them it's going to be an action-packed
night ken coleman dr john daloni rachel
cruz george campbell and me we're going
to be talking about what is going on
what in the world is going on what is
going on in the world and all about
building wealth and all about the
inflation stuff that's going on there's
a lot of craziness out there folks and
it's affecting how people are thinking
about their money and therefore it's
affecting how some people are doing with
their money but you're going to walk
away
calm yeah
deliberate plan we're going to show you
what to do why to do it logical
exactly what's going on
and uh you will do what we always do
around ramsey we're going to increase
your hope
it's what we do so come on out las vegas
building wealth live event
thursday night tomorrow night and uh
and we'd love to have you it's that
simple orlando we're going to be there
in two weeks on the 19th
and we're from tomorrow we're excited
about that uh we've got the entree
leadership summit the following week
there in orlando i think there's like
five tickets available for that that's
basically sold out but the building
wealth event in both of these cases is
up over 2 000 tickets sold approaching 3
000 tickets sold thank you for that
orlando thank you for that las vegas but
there are still seats available in both
of these venues uh we don't have a need
to declare a sell-out because we don't
hype stuff uh when there's still seats
if there's two seats left we'll tell you
so come you know we want you we want to
get as many people in there as we can
because we want to help people that's
what we do 25 for a ticket or you can
get a four pack for only 60 dollars so
you
you and your wife you and your husband
get onto
get a pair of tickets for your friends
and all four of you come make a night of
it it'll be a blast we'll be signing
books answering questions and uh
dr delony and king coleman will be
hosting a free bonus section about work
and relationships before the main event
yeah in each of these and so you don't
want to miss that i want to put out we
are trying to get permission from the
church to see if we can bring a tiger on
the stage so that's an extra bonus for
that because it's vegas we thought let's
try to get a tiger we haven't run that
by you this i'm hitting you with this
now but it's a pre-show bonus a little
hype after you said we don't hype things
yeah dr john delaney and i and a tiger
in vegas come on last guy that did that
it didn't work out for him i'm just
saying there's another guy who tried
that okay
and i thought i thought i'd spring that
one on yeah no pun intended yeah
oh i'm i'm i'm
speechless but i am now
every once in a while
i've got this visual of this kitty
walking off with ken in his jaws okay
and so i'm just
trying to clear that's worth the tickets
right there yeah so that that's worth
that's worth 25 i'm just easy easy it's
a deal of the century it is right there
wow thank you for joining us all right
did you get tickets at
ramseysolutions.com
slash events um
and you can come see tiger king there
you go i got it folks
this is great ken coleman's new nickname
tiger king
all right all right just wow
i knew you were gonna be a big hit
someday ken i just didn't know why
erica
erica's in des moines hey erica what's
up
hi guys um thank you for taking my call
you're welcome how can we help
hi so i am a 23 year old i am on baby
step 3b slash 4 and i am graduating with
my masters in accounting this weekend
awesome congratulations
thank you
i had a question about
finding
finding a job in
a field that aligns with what my
education is
what my master's education is or finding
a job
that aligns more with what my undergrad
is because my undergrad is
in one of dave's famous left-handed
puppetry
degree
what is it you got to tell us now
um it's
western equestrian studies and equine
business management so horse training
basically ah
well that's not left-handed puppetry i
mean we're talking about big business
there it's pretty nuanced but yeah yeah
yeah okay so when somebody represents
some people that have actual jobs doing
that oh yeah i mean and that's a big big
industry
so
undergrad versus
mba
want to do it is and i'm questioning is
there is there a little bit more
desire and excitement related to either
the undergrad or the masters or are they
equally just eh
um you know i love being outside and you
know not
working the nine-to-five desk job that
kind of scares me um but just being able
to kind of have a schedule that you know
i don't have to necessarily
answer to anybody
um and you know working outside helping
people with their horses helping people
why would you not have to answer to
anybody
if you're working for a company they're
going to expect you to produce crap
yeah but not answer it like
you know working with the horses i
wouldn't necessarily i could be my own
boss necessarily
yeah so that's what you want to do you
want to work with horses you want to
start your own business
yeah that's a different equation right
okay third third variable of the
conversation but horses is where you
want to go correct
yeah okay so why did you get an mba you
must have thought this is going to help
me somehow some way what did you think
the benefit was
because i see a lot of people in the
industry that um like i see a lot of
potential to improve and help people
improve their business tactics in the
industry
because
a lot of people you know get the
reputation for being
dumb horse people that don't know how to
run a business okay see i don't think
this is an either or i think it's both
and
i think you get into the field you start
working with horses in whichever way you
wanted to and now you're getting real
life experience and you're not only just
getting experience but you're getting
perspective you working for somebody and
in the horse business and you're not
just taking care of a horse in a certain
way as it relates to your job
description but your your head's on a
swivel you're asking the person you work
for your leader the owner all kinds of
questions about the business why do you
do this could you do this better you
become a student while you're a worker
and then with that mba and that training
of business training you grow yourself
into your own company eventually so i
think it's both and
okay based on what you said okay
now i will give you one guard rail on
that okay
that is not saying take a job for ten
dollars an hour shoveling out the
stables right when you could have made
85 grand as an accountant
yeah with this yeah i've been there yeah
so i mean i need you to step into a a
middle management
you know business oriented
good-sized organization
making some good money
in the horse world
even if you're not making quite what you
could make doing accounting and with the
game plan of going up but this idea that
you know i have to
you know i have to wax the saddles and
uh whatever else in order for five years
in order to be no well no no i'm not
saying that no i'm just saying don't do
that yeah not at all
yeah sure yeah i tried that and that's
not no
we we don't need you to turn into an
intern with a master's degree that's not
necessary
okay yeah so get if you but yeah there's
no reason i'm not the horse world
as you know and you know it better than
i do erica but i know enough to be
dangerous
it ranges everything from a 250 use
chevy pickup to a bentley
yeah and so you know you want to be over
on the bentley side working on this
stuff
you don't need to be trying to get some
guy who's got three hay seeds to make
money with them
yeah okay so get where somebody's
dealing with some expensive horse flesh
and there's some money flying around
this thing
and
you know
that way they can pay you
because there's going to have to be some
flex there so if you're dealing with
cheap horses the employees are going to
be cheap that's what i'm saying
and so and horses
like everything else or most everything
else there's a tremendous spectrum
on what people spend for them
so good stuff good luck with that kiddo
sounds like a lot of fun sounds like you
got a great adventure ahead of you this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage kevin
and alyssa are with us hey guys how are
you we're doing fabulous dave how are
you better than we deserve welcome to
nashville where do you live
we live in sullivan indiana it's a very
small rural community near what near
terre haute okay that'll work well
welcome good to have you guys how much
debt have you paid off
we paid off 72 000
and we cash flowed 18 000 of that
towards my master's degree good for you
and your range of income or how long did
that take you it took us 26 months good
and your range of income during that two
years
range of income was started at 90 000
and we today we're at 152. wow nice jump
what do y'all do for a living
well i'm a history teacher for a high
school called dugger union community
schools and i'm also in the indiana air
national guard great your master's in
history it is in history excellent good
okay and i work full time as a federal
employee
and i work part-time as an elected
official on my local school board
just to clarify a different school board
than alisa uh so there's no nepotism
there oh i don't know i thought i
thought you were setting up job security
for the history teacher here i don't
know man this is a yeah we can lay off
everybody but that particular history
teacher yeah
yeah very good guys very good cool so
what kind of debt was this 72 000
well dave we're a little weird we paid
off our mortgage whoa
you're more than a little weird you're
actually very weird congratulations
thank you how old are you guys i'm 31
i'm 35. and you have a paid for house
yes that makes you weird right there i'm
just what's the house worth uh in
today's market it's about 200 000.
i love it
how does it feel to not have a payment
in the world in your 30s free
very free yeah that's pretty incredible
wow
i mean most people never even think
about paying off their mortgage and you
guys do it in your early 30s what in the
world inspired all of this
well about 26 months ago we happen to be
looking at our amortization schedule i
got that right here yep happen to have
it yeah i just happened to have our
amortization schedule
and we were looking at our mortgage
payment and we realized how much we were
paying to the bank in interest
over half of our mortgage payment every
single month was going to interest and
very little was actually going towards
the principal yeah and so that upset us
because we were just basically throwing
money at the bank and so you know it's
amazing there's a couple of times people
really get upset about math one of them
is the first time you ever get a
paycheck and they hold taxes out
and you go what and the second time is
when you figure out how bankers make
money yeah yeah right we were definitely
giving the bankers a lot of money and so
we decided we're not doing that anymore
let's pay off our mortgage and get this
done and over with i love it wow boom
how'd you get introduced to ramsey
well dave we've been following the baby
steps for years uh been following i've
called on the ken coleman show show
twice so we love you guys uh we're a big
fan so
we followed the baby steps from step one
all the way to now we're on step seven
so yeah we've paid off all the
non-consumer debt and or the
non-mortgage debt and that was seventy
seven thousand dollars actually and uh
we got to the point to pay off the
mortgage
and we that's when we uh just tackled it
just looked down and went i only got two
years i can be done
yeah and actually david uh
it was supposed to be four years that
was our goal
so
kind of to skip ahead just a little bit
um
so we set a goal uh 26 months ago ago as
a god goal to say you know how can we
pay this mortgage off in four years and
we said
mathematically it can't happen uh we
just don't have the income
but we had faith and we had the faith
that lord the lord would provide for us
and
we just put our heads down and we're
grinding
and
um a friend of ours has a good quote
when you live in the kingdom you can't
lose
and so our number one uh piece of advice
and our thing here is get into the
kingdom
and the lord provided and whether it was
stimulus money that we would get we
didn't need it but we took it and we
just put it right towards a mortgage
and
we just kept on
um
we were blessed so much and we just
continued to be blessed because
it allowed us to pay it off not in four
years but in 26 months yeah i i can't
prove it theologically or biblically but
just observation for 30 years i swear i
think god is standing around waiting on
someone
to start behaving
you know and start going oh well there's
two that actually get it i can give them
some money they're they're worthy of
trust they are trustworthy oh they're
they'll look at those two i can give
them some money
and and i can give them a chance to go
make some more money because you're not
afraid of work you know and so because
we know that god provides for the birds
but he does not throw the worms in the
nest
uh they leave the nest go get the worms
out of the ground and that's what you've
been doing you've been working but god
gave you open doors gave you options
ways to do it uh so that you could
prosper that's strong man i love that
thank you
good job you guys yeah yeah i first real
quick question favorite period of
history
i would probably have to say world war
ii is one my favorite okay cool i just
had to ask uh so when you guys decided
you'd already paid off debt previously
and now you go okay we get after the
home and so i'm just curious having gone
through the first part of that now
coming after the home what did you take
from the first part of that journey of
the consumer debt and all this other
stuff and how did it inform this journey
make you a little bit more effective i'm
just curious what you learned and then
what you put into play as a result yeah
great question ken so uh the first the
first part we we learned about the
journey in itself so when you set a big
goal
when you're on that journey
it's the process of that journey that
shapes you and shifts you and makes you
a more refined person
you start building better daily habits
you start building better financial
habits healthy eating habits and
so we just took those principles in the
first
few baby steps and then applied them to
this baby step and and it's like this
snowball it got rolling and we couldn't
stop it and um
what
yeah we were just so blessed with that
um we just continued to work hard and uh
follow the principles you guys talk
about them all the time and we just put
them into practice that's great way to
go you guys very well done favorite
period in history i'm gonna guess
founding of the nation you know that
revolutionary warfare right he's a
history nut okay so which is fun to
travel with if you're touring if you're
turning cities like boston right so um
yeah he knows more than the stupid
travel travel guide or whatever the guy
was walking around remember that guy oh
never forget that was interesting so hey
way to go you guys what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
yeah the key is uh number one get into
the kingdom uh number two
set big goals goals so big they scare
you and because when you're on that
journey that's when you you start
becoming a better person and learning um
we would also say you're going to face
adversity
there's no question it's murphy's going
to hit you or you're going to fail
you're going to make bad decisions but
you just never give up what was the
biggest uh adversity you had to leap
over in this 26 months
26 months the biggest piece of adversity
um probably be our vehicles yeah our
vehicles are 10 and 12 years old they
constantly break down there's adversity
sitting in your driveway yes every
single day and actually we just got one
of our vehicles back out of the shop we
had to get a alternator replaced and
you know it's like we could have very
easily went and bought a brand new
vehicle but
it is time for you to move up in car now
okay i mean you can wait you can let all
these used car prices come down a little
bit that's right you guys need some cars
way to go you guys you're amazing well
done
very well done we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's for
sure your next chapter in this story
very well done and also a copy of total
money makeover for you to give away and
get someone else started on the process
bring the kids up and give us their
names and ages
this is aryan she's nine years old
this is amira she's seven years old
this is kansas she's six years old and
this is kylie she's 15 years old all
right very cool very cool well done uh
so dad i believe the ladies have ganged
up on you in this family wow absolutely
well done very well done all right kevin
and alyssa kylie aaron adrian aryan
aryan i'm sorry amira amira i can't do
any of it in kansas i'm messing it all
up from indiana 72 000 paid off in 26
months making 90 to 152 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream you ready
ladies
thank you for changing our family tree
dave three two one we're we're dead
[Applause]
be t-shirts say straight out of debt for
those of you listening on the radio
i love it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
best-selling author and host of the ken
coleman show is my co-host today as we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual
real relationships caitlin is with us
caitlin's in memphis hi caitlin welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave and ken how are you guys good
what's up
great so i'm 23 years old i just
graduated with my master's on april 30th
congratulations
awesome
thank you in cyber security oh wow
cha-ching yeah yeah
did you hear that sound that you hear
that printing press sound in the
background folks that's money
yeah she knows it too that's the laugh
of ah you're right
good for you
so
thank you so my mother um informed me
that um she has zero save for retirement
and expects me to
take care of her during her retirement
years oh um obviously i don't want to
abandon my mother so how can i best
prepare myself to take care of her when
that time comes
you're 23.
how old is your mother
she is 46 sir
okay
so what part of her childhood trauma
has damaged her psychologically to make
this ridiculous butt statement
that i am not sure
do you agree that that's absolutely
ludicrous for a 46 year old to put on a
23 year old that you're gonna have to
take care of me someday when you've got
20 more years to work you ought to be
taking care of yourself
when you put it that way sure um
but
i do love my mother it's not a question
of loving your mother it's not a
question of honoring your mother
your mother's misbehaving
does she work now does she have any type
of career or job or there's some type of
uh challenge she's dealing with that
makes her put this on you what's what's
the back story
she does work um she's a secretary and
making around 30k a year
i just think it's uh it's a matter of um
not knowing
how to get to
since she hasn't saved it to this point
i think it's a matter of not knowing
when it's how to start
or
you know that type of thing was this a
flipping comment or you think she
seriously expects you to just to write
her checks when she retires because
she's worked her whole life and didn't
bother
i think it's 100 percent serious okay
okay all right
well there's two or three issues going
on okay issue number one is the answer
to your question is how do you help
anyone financially you first have to put
your own oxygen mask on meaning you
can't help people if you're broke so you
need to become wealthy and you're going
to do that you're going to be making a
lot of money and you're going to follow
the baby steps that we teach and you're
going to stay out of debt and you're
going to invest and save and you're
going to be a multi-millionaire
by the time you're 40
okay
and so you'll be able to write her
checks
that does not mean you should but
mathematically you would be able to if
you followed that do you agree with that
yes sir okay then the next part of the
question for me is
um how do we honor
the office
of motherhood
in other words the bible says honor your
father and mother it does not say buy
them cocaine if they are a cocaine
addict
that is not honoring them
and so we don't the bible is not
suggesting that by honoring your parents
you participate in their misbehavior
and for a 46 year old to plan on
retiring broke and be taken care of by
their children is misbehavior in the
american culture
now in some cultures it would not be but
in north america in memphis tennessee
that's misbehavior
you follow me
yes sir so how can we help mom when mom
is engaged in
misbehavior behavior that's
inappropriate
uh and so what i would do is this i i
would say hey mom i'm going to go
through this class because i'm going to
start making a lot of money call
financial peace university to learn how
to handle money and man i really want
you to go with me would you go with me
mom
and i'll pay for it and let's get her in
this class and teach her how to handle
money
and let's get her believing having some
hope that she actually could have the
dignity of controlling her own
destination without depending upon her
daughter because i got to tell you i
don't know what kind of person it is
that actually feels okay about
themselves
when they are
planning to fail
and dump it on their own kids
i don't think she feels good about
herself
when she says that
or
she does
if she does then somebody needs to bust
her
and we can take care of either one we
can help her by busting her or we can
help her that's right
and caitlyn
having some hope again and going okay
hey let's take this 32 000 let's
motivate you to get that income up let's
motivate you to get your budget going
and start saving because she honestly
should be able to take care of herself
and i can show her how and i will show
her how and i'll pay for it yeah caitlin
what's missing here is your mom simply
doesn't know that's what you said
earlier in the call she just doesn't
know
and so if you could take her to that
class and then begin to cast a vision
for her to show her at the age of 46 if
she puts away this amount of money per
year over the next 20 years where she
can get to she just needs to see some
vision as well so don't just take her to
the class and encourage your shower but
begin to take that knowledge that dave's
going to teach in that class and show
her how to see
what she could actually do and a lot of
times dave ignorance is debilitating
yeah you don't know and so you become
hopeless and then you do
stupid stuff like you know dump this on
your 23 year old kid yeah it's just
absurd so
um
i i want you to hear i'm i'm uh
the main thing i want you to come away
from this conversation with caitlin
is the courage to say
mom you are responsible for you i'm
don't need to be
and no i don't accept this assignment
and i do love you and oh by the way this
woman right here she could be a travel
agent for guilt trips sometimes can she
yes sir yeah and so don't don't don't
cash the ticket in on the guilt trip
just go yeah i know
i'm one of four kids who
like not to
you know
throw dirt on my siblings but i'm the
one who quote unquote made it out and
actually did something yeah with my life
yeah you're gonna because you're gonna
go big your income's gonna be more than
your brothers and sisters put together
oh yes sir i'm starting with 100k yeah
yeah and you're going and you're going
to 200 and then i blink in your world if
you're smart as i think you are
and caitlyn but that does not mean you
have to take care of everybody that
won't take care of themselves right
that is not a moral obligation on your
part
and i want to set you free from that
then if you choose to turn around once
you're emotionally free from this toxic
argument this toxic mandate that's
coming at you once you're emotionally
free from that if you still choose to
come back as a position of strength when
you don't have to but even though i
don't have to i want to i'm still going
to be kind and i'm going to help some
people that didn't that are in a mess
then that's fine
that's fine but i don't want you signing
up at 23 years old for a 46 year old
babysitting job that's just ridiculous
that's right and caitlyn i would also
tell you if you're not careful there's
an emotional trap in this relationship
and here's the trap
mom puts the pressure on you to do this
you love your mom you don't want to
disappoint mom so here's what happens
you do something that inherently you
know you shouldn't have to do
and in trying to please your mom you end
up resenting your mom yep and what dave
is telling you to do is
uh you need to be okay disappointing mom
but in disappointing her hopefully
pointing her to a better future and then
in the end you won't resent her and so i
would always rather disappoint a family
member or friend
than i would resent them because see the
disappointment is on her side the
resentment will stay with you the rest
of your life and so you got to be
careful of the emotional trap here
here's the last part of the story and
then we're basically i want you to hold
on kelly's going to sign you and your
mom up for financial peace university
i'm going to pay for it i want you guys
to go to class okay we want to help you
fix this problem but here's the last
part
when you meet a guy
if he's a really good guy
uh and he wants to be your husband and
you want to be his wife
and you fall in love
he's not gonna like this deal
he's not gonna like this obligation that
comes
with this deal
i've met this great gal but she insists
on taking care of her mother who won't
take care of herself
that's
how can i say this highly unattractive
that's a good way of saying it there you
go okay
it's ugly all right hold on kelly i'll
pick up and uh we'll get you signed up
for financial peace university this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality host of the ken
coleman show and author of the number
one bestseller from paycheck to purpose
he is my co-host today as we answer your
questions and help people build wealth
do work that they love
and create actual
amazing relationships
garrett is going to start us off at this
hour he is in sioux falls south dakota
hi garrett what's up
mr ramsey it's time to ask you how you
are better than i deserve sir what's up
good to hear
well uh the company i work for i think
uh might be in trouble for the last five
ten years we've done ten to twelve
million dollars in revenue
made five to ten percent every year
this year we're showing negative 1.6
million dollars bottom line
cash flow is good
um
i just
i don't know what to do
uh
you own the company you said you work
for them
i work for them i work pretty closely
with the owner okay what do you do
uh so i'm a project estimator project
manager
i'm trying to help with the financials i
have college of principles i'm debt-free
i'm trying to
bring them into the company i'm in talks
with netsuite right now to get them set
up with our company good
and we're just
trying to understand
how we're showing 1.6 million dollars in
a loss right now
our base expenses are payroll fuel and
repairs
well let's start with a simple equation
that profit is created by revenue minus
expenses right
yes sir so what's down or what's up
expenses up and revenue's down what's
the deal
i think
for the revenue for this time of year is
down quite a bit
i think expenses for hourly rates have
gone
up
we do hourly jobs and we do big jobs
for the bid jobs we show positive
revenue or positive profit for that job
you're an estimator if your hourly has
gone up on the individual jobs that's a
variable expense that should be built
into the job cost
correct have you have you not added it
to the job costs and added profit on top
of it
hourly shouldn't on in hourly that is
they can be costed out job costed to a
job
you as an estimator know that that
should not have have sunk you it should
have just raised the cost of the
customer
right and
there are several divisions in our
company and
i've i've spent a few times or a few
days analyzing our hours for last year
and marking that against our
our overhead for the year and those
rates seem pretty high and
sometimes they're just not used and they
go with
their gut feeling
because if we charge you know four
hundred dollars for a dozer they're just
gonna tell us no so we have to try and
make no is good if you're losing a
hundred dollars when you charged 400
you'd have been better off to park it
so you don't lose money when it's parked
okay
i mean
i don't if if if the rate if the cost of
the dozer operator
now makes the rate for a dozer 500 and
you're only charging 400
that's why you're losing money you
raised your prices after your labor cost
went up
okay am i missing something better off
no sir so better off not to work for
those companies if they won't accept our
rates
exactly because guess what everybody's
got the same problem you got
you didn't just pay your dozer operators
way more than everybody else the cost of
a dozer operator went up
i got the same thing internally except i
don't have dozer operators i've got
developers
i got programmers the tech world
uh and you know the only thing they're
dozens ones and zeros but they're dozing
them and so uh but the uh
you know the cost of a developer has
gone up dramatically in 24 months and
guess what that's going to be reflected
in what you guys pay
to go to a ramsey whatever
you know because
i
you know i'm going to pas business
owners pass those costs along
corporations don't lose money they they
raise their prices
companies don't hire the rates we need
to project how much overhead we think
we're going to have for the year and
then
project how many hours we're going to
use that dozer for and then divide that
and then add 10 to that and then that's
what we should charge yeah what most
companies do and you're in estimators
you probably already know all this but
what most companies do is they say okay
here's the cost of them
of the cost of goods sold here's the
materials
the the equipment usage and the labor
associated with the job
okay and that's the dozer the dozer
operator the fuel the truck costs to
move the dozer to the site okay all of
that is job costed you know what i'm
saying right garrett yep okay then most
companies in addition to that will
allocate a an overhead percentage to
that job
and you can determine the overhead
percentage however you want you can do
it based on gross revs and say okay we
got a 10 million dollar gross rev this
is a million dollar job so this job gets
10 of our overhead
you see how i did that
a pro rata allocation of overhead to
each job and you need to be job costing
out your overhead and then adding profit
to both the actual cost of the job the
job costed overhead together then put a
profit on top of that and bang you're
back profitable again but i think two
things have happened one is you guys
were pretty disorganized on some of
these smaller jobs the bigger jobs
you're doing a good job of running the
job cost on and you're accounting on
these smaller jobs sucks and you're
guessing
i think you're correct on that yeah
you would be a normal 10 million dollar
company that's what we were doing we
were 10 million our accounting sucked
when we were 10 million dollars we were
and i'm the money guy and our accounting
was horrible
and but today man it's so freaking
dialed in it's unbelievable and so
you're really doing a good job a good
thing here so your uh leadership team
needs to get into entre leadership
yesterday and our guys can coach you
guys through this
but this is a uh first you got to know
where you are and get this get these
numbers dialed in to each job and get
and get the overhead dialed in and then
start an allocation of overhead formula
of some kind and then add profits to the
top of that then that will tell you how
to raise your prices and this is going
to go away but what happened was you
were out earning your stupidity
yeah you were making you're making
enough money that you're sloppiness
you're getting away with it there's also
one other thing going on here garrett
and i heard it when you said it we're
well we have to say no then we have to
walk away from a company don't want to
pay it you don't get to exclude yourself
from the marketplace inflation is a
function of all of this and so your
hourly wages have gone up the cost of
fuel which makes that dozer more
expensive so you you don't you guys are
worried about the goal we don't like
that well tough
because you just got to stand your
ground and explain basic economics to
these folks
across town has the same fuel problem
and they have the same labor cost that's
right
and so if they're not going to go up on
their price you're going to be buying
their machines at a nickel on the dollar
when they go broke
so they're every but this is why the
cost of bread has gone up because the
cost of fuel to deliver the bread has
gone up the 10 guy that used to put the
bread on the shelf is now a 20 guy those
those numbers are all built into the
cost of bread and so if you want a
universal wage guess who's going to pay
for it you are because you're going to
cut it's going to be absorbed into the
cost of that loaf of bread you do not
get to pass on this stuff like you're a
magic fairy one oh my gosh
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
so ken um
[Music]
what is the worst gift
you have ever been given
[Music]
uh i think for christmas one year i got
uh i got uh like some socks from
somebody that was very excited about the
christmas gift being socks
that's like something out of a movie
yeah yeah i don't have anything
sensational but that made me laugh yeah
well we like giving things ray ramsey oh
and uh so don't worry we aren't uh gonna
re-gift you a tacky white elephant gift
that your aunt gave you we're not gonna
give you ken's socks that's a blessing
uh we are going to give you the best
gift ever
cash
we're giving away five hundred dollars
every week and a grand prize of three
thousand dollars at the end of may with
our ramsey cash giveaway think about
what you can do three thousand dollars
to enter the giveaway go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway you can
enter every day
that way you got more chances to win no
purchase is necessary you got to be 18.
as great as the ramsey cash giveaway is
we're not stopping there to help you
crush your financial personal and
professional goals we're putting
our number one best-selling books and
tools in the ramsey
well we'll put them in the ramsey store
up for the ten dollar sale ten dollars
each that's 67 percent off
now if you need a proven plan for
getting out of debt that's the total
money makeover 10 bucks ken coleman's
getting hired digital course in addition
to the ramsey 10 sale just added that
these books and tools will help you make
a plan today to crush your goals
sixty-seven percent off the ramsey ten
dollar sale at
ramseysolutions.com or ramsey
solutions.com giveaway to sign up for
the free
giveaway our question of the day comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from nick in california i have an mba
and work as a mechanical engineer for a
construction company i'm not happy with
my job because the construction industry
is incredibly repetitive i would love to
work in research and development with a
focus on robotics and nanotechnology for
the military how do i know if making a
career change is a good idea and where
do i start okay so you're very very
clear on where you want to uh go and so
we're going to start with a three-part
formula to get clear that yes in fact
this is a good idea so we start with
nick do you have the talent and skills
necessary to win in robotics and
nanotechnology meaning basic talent that
with the proper training can be honed
into skills then you ask yourself
would i love actually working in
robotics and nanotechnology how do you
figure that out you talk to people who
are in robotics and nanotechnology you
get a good idea and your heart's going
to indicate whether or not you would
enjoy the work and then does it create a
result that matters to you i think the
answer on this one is yes you've chosen
the military there's a
protectiveness something that you
believe is honorable in doing this kind
of work for the military so i think the
answer is yes on the mission does it
create a result that that i value now
where do i start if we find out that yes
i've got the chops and i've got the
juice for the work where do i start if
it's for the military this question
doesn't make it completely clear but
this is either obviously
in the military serving directly for our
country or for a defense contractor that
would do this work for the military so
in either way we now say okay this is
the mountaintop i want to do robotics
and nanotechnology who's doing this what
companies are specifically providing
this work for the military and so we
begin to target them and we ask
ourselves all right what qualifications
do i need
what do i need to learn and what do i
need to do this is going to inform
where i start and starts the key here
think of this nick as getting on the
right ladder
and now i'm going to climb the ladder to
where i'm doing that work
that's very good
so um
if i'm making your career changes this
is a good idea
assuming the pay is equal or more and
it's in the field that you're generally
trained in
and you already have this dialed in it
saw it scratches the itch so if you're
making the same or more it's a
no-brainer to do it oh yeah yeah you
know so yeah we're gonna go is it a good
idea yes it's a good idea then where do
you start ken just laid all of that out
in great detail for you so
yeah you need to
uh uh
but there's
don't get yourself caught up in oh i've
got to go
get a master's degree before i can do it
because i don't think you do yeah um i
think you've got to get in there you've
got to meet some people
uh the proximity principle that's right
in in the industry that you want to be
in and you know right now you hang
around with construction people
and you need to be hanging around with
robotics and nanotechnology people
that's right by the way the four
questions you ask them these are four
qualifying questions number one what do
i need to learn that is is it an actual
degree or some type of certification or
training number two what experience do i
need that's what i need to do three how
much is that gonna cost me time and
money and then once i know that uh how
long will this take is the fourth
question dave that's that's those four
questions
simple questions by the way and when we
get those answers here's what comes out
of that a plan oh i need to learn this i
need to do this it's going to cost me
this as a result of my financial reality
so in order to budget in order to not
just jump off the bridge and hope
there's water
um
we're gonna actually
you know uh plot this out
and then take a step and then take
another step and then take another step
incrementally to where when you make the
move it's instantaneously
a smart idea that's correct yeah that is
the gradual incremental step-by-step
process that matters brayden is with us
braden's in memphis hi braden welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
so i just got a quick question for you
so me and my wife are um we're both 22
and we're debt-free like as a month and
a half ago
and uh
so we've
kind of just been chilling you know
relaxing and now i'm kind of just i'm so
used to being gazelle contin
gazelle in tents now i'm kind of feeling
like i don't know what to do i'm
honestly kind of getting a little bored
because i don't have like an object
to achieve good for you so i'm invested
into retirement and everything but i'm
just wondering kind of like what's next
um you know what should i what kind of
goal should i sit
so you have a paid for house
yes sir what's it worth
about 215. what do you guys do for a
living
i work for my dad as a herbiculturist
is that your long-term dream
take over the business or do you wanna
do something else
yeah i'm gonna take it over good okay
what's your wife do
she actually just does a little bit of
photography on the side but takes care
of what do you make
i make around 80. okay okay cool
so you have a 215 000 house you make 80
you're 22 years old and you have zero
debt of any kind
she makes about 30. so 110 total okay
110 household income okay cool yeah all
right
well i think you start laying out you
know what are some of our goals there
are three things you can do with money
and you should always do these three
things you can be generous with it
giving it
you can enjoy it and you should
and you can invest it and you should and
you do need to set some very clear
high definition very uber clear goals of
where you want to be and it can be a
random thing i want to have a million
dollar net worth i want to move to a
house it's 600 000 for my house it's 200
i want to pay cash for that difference
that's 400. now how long am i going to
do that well it's going to take me
six years or whatever i don't know right
and you start laying your numbers out
and then you've got something to plop
that money towards each time it comes in
and um
uh because right now the money is just
kind of wandering it doesn't have an
assignment when it comes in and you're
bored and you feel disjointed a little
bit but you need to have it a you know i
i'm one of my goals was to give away a
million dollars in a year one time
and then once i did that one of my other
goals was to give away a million dollars
in one day
and i've been able to hit both those so
i had to have a new goal on my
generosity goals and so um pretty cool
it's been fun so you gotta you know you
start but i'm i'm like three times older
than you so you got plenty of time to
pull this off i'm wondering if you want
to give a million dollars to me dave i
don't thought maybe that that's your
list well i'm just going to give you a
tiger
that's all you get a tiger
that's great you get a tiger
it's a million-dollar tiger though well
that it's one way of looking at it
you're going to be well known when this
is over you're going to be known for
ken coleman the tiger king
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage alex and courtney are
with us hey guys how are you good good
thank you welcome good to have you guys
where do you all live st louis missouri
all right good to have you fun
and how much debt have you paid 150 800
good for you and how long did this take
uh four years and three months all right
good and your range of income during
that time uh when we got married in
april of 2018 we started at 140 000 and
this past year just over 205. cool what
do y'all do for a living
i'm a senior recruiter for a technology
company based in st louis
i work first head technology company in
st louis i was an i.t project manager oh
were you recruited by me
that's what i was asking yeah wow yeah
definitely
before or after you got married
uh right before he started like six
months before he got married oh wow okay
so you recruited your own fiance i know
and now we have great jobs so he's very
happy awesome that is cool
very good move i'm just saying did you
get any pushback from the company uh
because he was your fiance
um if anything they liked him more
because i feel like they really like me
it was the team i was recruiting for um
so she kind of agrees with the skits for
him yeah she made it easy for him so
welcome
it's like having the older sister or
older brother in elementary school that
actually got good grades then when you
come in they expect you to get good
grades so there you go all my friends
are just my friends because of stacy so
i mean it's just the deal you out
married yourself that's a good good good
look well done well done i love it you
guys so what kind of debt was this 151
000
we paid off her house
love it wow you guys are killing it so
you get married in 2018 in the first
order of businesses knock out the house
yeah actually um we were on a vacation
shortly after we got um
engaged which we could afford we've
never really been bad at
money we just didn't really have a plan
and so we were in park city with some
friends and they mentioned they were
reading your book um so we ordered it
and then just kind of took off from
there just like that we were already
pretty good but this just tweaked a few
things and boom three years after
marriage our house was paid for what's
this house worth uh 280 to 300 roughly
how old are you two
i just turned 32. uh 35. 32 and 35 with
a paid for house
that was our last debt free screamer in
the other hour i know there's a pass 32
and 34 with a paid for house yeah lee
man yeah we're we're changing this
nation
uh yeah quick question on that do you
guys worry much about inflation
[Laughter]
there's a direct correlation to that
dave yeah not not having a house payment
i'm not worried about inflation who knew
who
i'm not worried about the price of cars
i've got one you know it's just
[Laughter]
you guys so cool so cool well done man
all right so you read the book you're
engaged
and you say okay we get married we're
actually doing this did one of you
already own this house
so um we did not have a house at that
point alex was debt-free i had like
seven thousand dollars on my car left so
after we finished the book i just wrote
a check and then that pretty much put us
in baby step b or 3b
um so we were planning the wedding a
honeymoon and saving for her house we
did all that early 2018
moved into the house
welcomed our first child in 2019 2019
and during that time we paused
everything
saved up cash for a mini whip
and then we um welcomed our daughter and
then we had another daughter in 2021 and
so when the youngest page turned seven
months we thought why not pay off the
house there we wrote our last mortgage
payment yeah just knock it out now that
we got this out of the way let's get
that out of the way wow boom boom boom
boom boom this is awesome way to go you
guys thank you how's it feel to not have
a payment in the world
feels great mm-hmm you don't owe anybody
at the end of the day it's a great day
yeah pretty fun
yeah and um dave i just want to tell you
like having a paid for house is awesome
but i think you always try and
capitalize on this during conversations
with people is take care of your family
life insurance put together a trust like
that at the end of the day for us
is so important we love knowing that if
anything would ever happen to us that
our kids are taken care of
so thank you for that direction you're
welcome that's awesome you're welcome
you all experienced that with one of the
parents or something or uh i did yeah
yeah i'm sorry
i saw the emotion so i knew i knew that
wasn't my voice gave me away i knew i
knew it was your heart did your heart
die i knew it was in an academic
discussion
so good well that's that makes it real i
mean and yeah you got to get you got to
have the whole package together
and then um
then you really are in the third pig
house the little the you know third
little pig the one that's in the brick
house and then when inflation comes i
was just being interviewed earlier today
by a journalist who was asking me how to
how people can survive inflation
and i said well you know we've got to
get out of the straw house now the house
of sticks move into the brick house and
that involves getting out of debt being
on a budget and uh you're not
bulletproof but you're a lot closer
a lot closer and the big bad wolf comes
and pandemic inflation
whatever world destabilization whatever
it is all these things we worry about
out there brick house is you guys are in
a paid for house you're 30 years old you
two babies
great career i mean you you really have
got yourself set up and then you do the
wills and the trust and the life
insurance and then we know everybody's
okay
yeah it's just that's amazing yeah so
you know dave said this for so many
years decades
you know if you live and give like no
one else later you can live and give
like no one else so we're looking at two
people who've done that and now here you
sit looking at the future to live and
give like no one else i just i want to
know what what is that what are you
thinking about dreaming about what's the
first next big purchase you got to have
something what's the celebration thing
we're doing uh
well we left the kids with grandma so
we're celebrating in nashville
start yeah the refrigerator already has
the next goal for us which is save up
and pay cash for the next house yeah
it's beautiful i like it i like it the
dream house
i like yeah well done and and so the
house is worth you said 300 280 to
380-300 and how much is in your 401ks
and i race about 350. okay all right so
um 47 i'm sorry uh 37 before you're 40
you're going to be
baby steps millionaires then that's the
plan and you know one of the reasons why
we wanted to start all of this is
because we didn't want to be 50 and look
back at and wonder like where did all of
our money go um and so you know we feel
so fortunate to know that we have this
plan together and we're moving up and we
are able to impact people's lives with
giving
talking to people and just being
hopefully an inspiration to people who
are listening as well yeah you guys are
incredible i'm so proud of you thank you
very very very well done who's your
biggest cheerleaders
um we had brian and leslie who were on
the stage a few years ago who paid off
their house two of our best friends my
mom his sister
a lot of people turn cheering us on yeah
very good good for you guys well we got
a copy of baby steps millionaires for
you so you complete that journey that's
the next chapter in your story for sure
and you got a great story because you've
chosen to make it a great story you
control the control the controllables
and that's what it's about very very
well done also a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away on a ski
trip but somebody's just started talking
about this you never know you may make
them into a millionaire by doing that
that's good stuff i like it all right
good stuff alex and courtney from st
louis 151
000 paid off in four years and three
months house and everything 32 and 35
making 140 to 205. they're a hundred
percent
debt free you're rocking it count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one
[Applause]
love it
about as good as life gets right there
about as good as life gets
what a great young couple and a great
start yeah
and here's the thing it doesn't matter
how old you are you're listening to this
watching this right now you can do it
uh if you're 55 you can do it if you're
45 you can do it if you're 25 you can do
it
and if you're 32 and 35
four years and three months ago
you can do it and they did it it's
pretty incredible and it's one of the
reasons we
continue to do the debt free screams
even though there's
literally thousands of them now on our
youtube channel you can just sit and
watch debt-free screams for days yeah
that's true literally days
yeah our youtube channel is our podcasts
are just exploding you guys thank you so
much we now have over one billion
downloads
on the podcast
with a bee that's just kind of bizarre
to think about
this is the ramsey shaft
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality host of
the ken coleman show author of the book
from paycheck to purpose
is my co-host this hour as we talk to
you about building wealth doing work you
love and creating actual
amazing relationships andrew is with us
andrew is in durham north carolina hi
andrew how are you
hey hello it's uh great to speak with
you too gentlemen thank you very much
our ownership
yes
uh i'm a grandfather mid 80s my wife and
i are well off financially actually
we've been debt-free for 30 years and we
visited your studio two years ago
wonderful wonderful experience here's my
question
we have five
young adult grandchildren one is 26
graduated college two years ago summa
[ __ ] laude great christian girl she took
an in a christian internship
that provided her a part-time job with
some lawyers and she finished the
internship and went on to
take the full-time position as a
paralegal
so she's making like in the mid 30s she
really dislikes the job she loves
writing
seems to have talent in that field she
wants to be in like journalism
broadcasting she has an opportunity to
attend
a one-year master's program at a
well-regarded northern university the
cost is about 75 000. she'll get a 25
000 scholarship she needs an additional
fifty thousand plus living costs uh my
concerns are this she's never worked in
the field that she's interested in and i
just wonder how you know how important
that would be in her career we're
thinking of helping
but maybe having some strings attached
maybe a loan from our family trust and
i'm just wondering how you would guide
her and my wife and myself
to help her to maximum ability
wow fantastic
question so
i think she needs to spend some time
with people that are in broadcasting or
journalism in the specific area that
she's interested in there might be two
or three different lanes and my advice
would be to have her spend some time
with them to learn the ins and outs and
what does a day look like what does the
financial path look like what does
growth look like not just in position
but also in income and then i would also
challenge her uh to uh reconsider the
prestigious university in the northeast
because nobody cares where a broadcaster
went to school
they just don't in fact
we don't even care where our doctors
went to school by evidence of the fact
that few of us ever asked where our
doctors went to med school and so the
scholarship of 25 000 at a very
prestigious school could probably be a
full scholarship potentially or
certainly less money for you to give to
her
to further her education and get that
experience i will say in broadcasting a
degree is not required at the age of 33
i made a pivot
to move into broadcasting and i had to
earn my way and figure out how to do it
on the side and eventually got dave
ramsey's attention
but there was no school or degree
involved it was just good old-fashioned
learning how to do broadcasting doing
small things while having a day job
and so i would say that in broadcasting
if she were to get a full ride
or you were to pay a lot less money for
a less prestigious school but that
one-year program got her some
real-life broadcasting experience in the
form of internships and some premium
placement
that could certainly help but it's not
necessary
so um
yeah
yeah i really appreciate your heart
andrew and the way you ask the question
the way you poised it is very loving but
it's also very wise and very practical
as would be expected from a man like you
um the uh the the thing is this okay i
i've been in broadcasting for 30 years i
work with
just about every major network that you
see or hear
on television or radio anywhere
on i i do interviews almost every week
with someone outside of here whether
they be in new york or california or
atlanta or durham north carolina even
and i got to tell you i don't think that
um
as a matter of fact i'm 100 positive
that a master's degree is not necessary
to be a writer and to be a journalist
it's simply not
and it's certainly not worth 75 000 for
a one-year program
there's no return on investment on that
the goal that your granddaughter has is
a valid goal and she has
discovered or has been told a mistaken
method to get to her goal
the ladder that she wants to use to get
to her goal is the wrong ladder it's not
a necessary ladder and it's super
expensive
and so um
i don't know that as a grandpa you'll be
able to talk her down off this thing
she's probably all
hyped up about going to this particular
school the prestige of it's got her all
jazzed and she's jonesed up with it uh
and she's got this idea that being a
master's is you know having a master's
is going to open all these doors and the
truth is it just doesn't
uh it doesn't you can either write and
you get in there and you start writing
and you write you learn the right copy
and you learn to communicate
verbally and you learn to work a stage
or a camera or a microphone depending on
which side of the thing you're going to
be on and what part of broadcasting and
journalism you're going to be involved
in
but uh you know here's the other thing
they don't make any money
it's not it's not a big lucrative career
and so i mean if you're a writer for a
major network in new york city
you make 50 or 60 grand
and you're 25 26 years old and they work
you 80 hours a week
and you know and so you can't justify a
75 000 additional expense to go do that
she's already got the skills to do it
and uh we work with those young people
every day and most of them are young
people uh in these roles and they're you
know they're they're you know they're
they're writing the teleprompter for the
script we're getting ready to do and the
interview and most people don't follow
it after they write it but it's done you
know and so i don't know how you're
going to talk her out of it
but boy if you could you should because
she's barking up the wrong tree she's
getting ready to spend a whole bunch of
money she doesn't need to spend to go do
something she doesn't need to do to get
to be who she wants to be yeah
and i actually do know something about
that you know we're actually right we're
in the middle of it right well neither
you or i have formal broadcasting
training we just started doing it and
you you stink at first yeah i mean
the number of people that we talk to
that are behind the scenes that are
writers oh yeah they're they're print
reporters in journalism or they're
script writers for shows uh and they're
trying to build you know what we call
produce a segment that's correct meaning
that we're working with fox and friends
and we're getting ready to go on fox and
friends and the producer that's
producing the segment
normally is 26 years old oh yeah no
master's and
well i don't know if she or he's got a
masters but i have no indication that
they do and i have no care if they do
right neither does uh steve do see when
he that's in front of the camera all he
wants to know is can we did we produce a
segment where it makes us logical it's
cogent the narrative is there the story
arc is there are we delivering in a
concise manner in basic journalism rules
and i mean you can get that in a
community college taking three writing
labs outside of that dave the very first
broadcasting and only broadcasting class
i ever took was 699 with a local tv and
radio producer he was legit in atlanta
and i was with a bunch of 20-somethings
and i learned things in that six-week
course
one night a week six weeks i learned
things in that course that i still use
today with you and it's the basic
fundamentals so who can teach me what i
actually need to learn is this question
we ask and andrew what we're all talking
about here is
you and ken and i
is where the education system and the
culture
are are uh
have misled
about the last three generations
and told them that where you go to
school matters
and that you always have to have more
school no matter what
and that
ridiculous levels of education are
necessary to pull off some of these
basic jobs
and they're not she has a four-year
degree she's been a paralegal she's
already doing writing all day long it's
just boring bad writing in the law
office you know and so she's fine uh i
would tell her to go to work
go to work in the journalism field
she unlock her job change jobs
and
and take you know take some night
classes on writing
and uh that's what i would do and i
would not loan her money
um and i would not give her money to do
something that is a path that i don't
believe is the correct path
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay
show you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour as we talk about your
life and your money we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing actual
relationships thanks for jumping in the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five
ken two years ago right now people were
locked down in their homes we had to
flatten the curve
you remember flattening the curve well i
remember hearing about it but it turns
out you and i and some brave staff
people kept coming in and putting out
live shows so i heard about it and we
heard about but the curve apparently had
to be flattened yes and then later
apparently two weeks as we had to be
masked and then apparently we didn't
yeah and then apparently we all had to
be vaccinated and then apparently we
didn't and
some people are still bathing in that
fair porn that's out there yes in the
middle of all of that there's um
a complete i mean we shut down the
american economy yes for
you know what 60 to 90 days and we're
now experiencing inflation as a result
of that
lack of production creating shortages
and now a
an over
zealous uh retail
thrive driving
supply have been driving demand way high
and supplies still out of kilter two
years later we're trying to recover from
the flattening of the curve
uh but one of the things i didn't know
until i picked up this from nbc news
this week
um
they're calling the ppp plan the biggest
fraud
in a generation the looting of the covid
relief plan yeah the remember ppp oh
yeah where businesses were not going to
you know the economy was going to
collapse if the government didn't step
in right just like we were all going to
die
we're all going to die if we didn't
flatten the curve right the economy was
going to collapse and everybody was
scared and everybody's running around
screaming and screeching at the top of
their lungs
and so the government lines up
this blows
my mind um
90 i mean i'm sorry
let's just say okay they bought
lamborghinis they brought ferraris and
bentley's here's the article and tesla's
of course lots of teslas many have
participated in what prosecutors are
calling the largest fraud in u.s history
the theft of hundreds
of billions
of dollars in tax care payer money
intended to help those harmed
by the covenant 19 pandemic
instead these
fraudsters came in and couldn't resist
purchasing luxury automobiles mansions
private jet flights and swanky vacations
they came into the riches by
participating in what experts say is the
theft of as much as
80 billion dollars
80 billion dollars oh yeah of the ppp
yeah was fraudulent use and theft of the
800 billion that was handed out in the
covid relief plan known as the paycheck
protection program or ppp that's on top
of the 90 billion to 400 billion
believed to have been stolen from the
other 900 billion under the covid
unemployment relief program right so
we've got 800 billion and 900 billion we
dumped into saving the world
well we have a theme dave so what
happens is when government says they're
going to come in to save the day
government doesn't operate efficiently
or effectively and what we had was a
small business administration on the
first half of this the ppp saying hey
write us a letter this is a this is
about as fundamental as it was and tell
us why you need it so what do these
people do these scumbags they go let's
take advantage of the us government
because they're a bunch of morons and
we're going to get money and they got it
well the government just said here's a
check here's a check here's a check
here's a check because they wanted to
save the day exactly well and the trump
administration truly believed and they
were screwed in the head
that
they had to get this money plugged into
the economy fast to offset
the the drop
to offset the quarantine right and when
you go
at that rate of speed you don't have any
way to verify
and put in place that's correct and you
drop trillions
and trillions of dollars out there and
now we're finding out
that well over 10
of it unbelievable
north of 500 billion dollars now
went to people
who did not have an unemployment problem
and did not even qualify for ppp because
all they did was say
sign this document and check here that
you really
are due this money right they didn't
even look no yeah i have 46 employees
i happen to work out in my basement have
no employees but i have 46 employees and
here's the name of my company people
were going to state records and pulling
company names off of state records and
filing under that with false addresses
basically creating a form of identity
theft and getting checks for hundreds of
thousands of dollars sent to them to
keep their business open and they didn't
even have a business yeah this is what
happens when leaders lead from
desperation desperation and fear that's
exactly what happens it was happening
it was full-on panic right and when
people are panicking they're not leaders
that's correct and i don't care if
you're a democrat you're a republican
you're a lefty you're a massacre you're
a righty you're an anti-massacre you're
a vaccer or you're an anti-vaxxer if
you're in a full-on panic you're
straight-up stupid that's right and so
what was happening is the government was
trying to give the illusion of we're in
control we got you and the fact of the
matter is they didn't and this is
taxpayer dollars let's bring this back
to when you hear numbers like that i
want to make sure you folks catch this
because those numbers are so big it kind
of feels like oh it's that's just so
that's your
money that is taxpayer dollars being
fraudulently spent and all because
leaders are trying to give the illusion
that they can solve your problems and by
the way they're the source of the
shutdown where the governors
and the senators
trump all of them they all signed on to
this
shutdown and it broke businesses and in
their desire to help the businesses they
broke
they end up wasting money and i got to
tell you something it ought to be a wake
up call to the america everybody ought
to stop and go
hey yeah
this is this whole thing yeah
was off yeah
yeah and let's stop blindly trying some
kind of bad movie right here
but
500
billion dollars
paid out to people that were didn't even
own businesses or that weren't even
unemployed
in the name of
panic
brought on by
false sets of assumptions about numbers
oh god it just is it's a
it's a case study in leadership
not leading
and in the nanny state run amok that's
true and so the people are screaming you
have to take care of us because now you
made us locked us in our house and now
you have to feed us yeah and uh man
people you people i'm telling you
if you ever allow your government to do
this to you again you're a bunch of
freaking sheep
but yeah because this the the results of
this
are going to ripple through our economy
for a decade
[Music]
500
million dollars and here's the deal you
can do something about trillion dollars
you know what you can do vote go vote
anybody that was a party to this kind of
google support oh
a governor to a senator to a president
you can vote send them home good god
this is the ramsay show
hmm
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
guys if you're wondering whether to buy
or sell a home this year we've got some
answers you can expect the market to be
a lot like last year
prices are still on the rise interest
rates are headed up too what does that
mean for you it means if you're buying a
home you might be up against some heavy
competition big price tags and a higher
interest rate and that can mean mortgage
payments that are higher so you need to
stick to your budget and if you want to
sell your home chances are you want to
sell it quickly and you want to sell it
for top dollar of course that's going to
depend on where you are every market's
different
to win on any market you really have to
know what you're doing and this is not
amateur hour right now you need a pro in
your corner you need an experienced real
estate agent at your fingertips and we
have them through our endorsed local
provider program as ramsay trusted
pros
they care about your values and they
keep well they help you keep more of
your money in your pocket so check out
ramseysolutions.com
agent connect with a ramsey trusted
real estate agent a pro
that can help you navigate this local
market that you are in
ramseysolutions.com
agent
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five jacob is in
toledo hi jacob welcome to the ramsey
show
hi guys how are you doing great man
what's up
uh
i've been a long time listener but i've
never put your
teachings into practice until finally
this year i decided to get serious and
last year i financed a vehicle and this
year i was able to sell it
and make a little bit of money back i
made about twenty five hundred dollars
after uh the lean was paid off
and uh
i was excited because i owe about four
thousand dollars in credit cards and i
was excited to take a chunk out of it
and i feel like the lord has put it on
my heart to
uh tithe it
um
i've kind of been tossing it back and
forth with my wife exactly how much
uh if we should do the whole thing if
it's smart to do it at all because i
know that we're we're still in a little
bit of debt i mean we're not crazy
into debt but we we have a little bit of
debt left to go and uh but i just feel
like it's just really been laying down
on me that
uh i should be giving this money that it
doesn't really belong to me
um and i just don't giving giving what
money how much money uh the the twenty
five hundred dollars that i uh the whole
2500
yes okay that's not a tithe
i will
a tithe is 10
a tie this 10 of your profit
that's a tithe
but if you want to be if you're you're
just saying you feel like the holy
spirit's leading you to just give
everything you made on this
yes okay yeah that's okay
i never argue with god if god is telling
you to do something do it okay i'm not
ever gonna do that i can give you the
biblical guidelines on tithing i can we
can talk through the technicalities of
that and we can pan back and say your
heavenly father is crazy about you and
he doesn't need your money
and none of the giving should ever be
done out of compulsion or guilt
or toxic twisting or anything else all
giving should be done out of an open
hand and an understanding that i really
just manage this for god anyway what do
you want me to do with a heavenly father
it's your money anyway and so if father
is saying
give the 2500 then do give the 2500 but
your biblical guideline on tithing
would be
simply you 10 of the profit you made on
the car the profit would be how much
more you sold the car for than what you
paid for it
would you pay for it
yeah right like i didn't
i would not say that i technically
profited uh there's not a tithe do so
we'll just change the language in this
discussion okay
okay yeah i'm sorry i i'm not gonna use
the wrong no no that's okay i just want
to make sure that we're clear i mean a
tithe is a tenth of your profits a tenth
of your increase from deuteronomy is the
scripture okay
so you don't have an increase on this
car you have a decrease you lost money
on the car in terms of what you bought
it for what you sold it for versus what
you bought it for but you got out of the
debt and you end up with some money in
your pocket and you do feel like god's
telling you to give that money then if
he's telling you that then give the
money i'm okay with that
okay yeah i just didn't want to be
stupid anymore you know what i mean yeah
i don't think it's stupid to follow if
you think it's god now i always
i mean i've been walking with god for 40
years and so
i'm always less so today than 40 years
ago but i i'm
never a thousand percent sure that i
heard god on something that is uh
different than scripture says
now if there's a scriptural guideline
then that's simple for me i'm gonna do
it okay
that's an obedience issue for me from a
faith walk all right but uh it's
something like okay you just made this
profit and you're trying to get out of
that or not profit you made this uh net
gain or net cash to your pocket cash
flow that you could throw at the debt or
you feel like god might be telling you
to give it then there's not really a
a biblical reference that says anything
other than be obedient to the holy
spirit now what i was going to say
though is i i still
wonder until i look back now i can
always look back and tell but in the
moment like you are you're facing this i
still sometimes have a little bit of
trouble discerning but the difference
between the holy spirit and last night's
pizza
uh indigestion okay so i mean is this
just guilt or is this something floating
around because you're finally starting
to get control i don't know any of that
but i never argue with someone when
someone plays the god card i back up and
go do whatever he said
yeah jacob i just want to ask you did
you
see something experience something and
you felt a tug on your heart and you go
i i could do something there i feel like
i want to do something is there
something specific on this
i just i just felt like
and i don't really like explaining it to
people just because
some people believe that some people
don't but
uh
and that's fine but i just felt like the
lord
i felt like somebody was telling me that
it belonged to him got it very good okay
i believe you i do too yeah no i will
tell you this
it does belong to him yes that's right
all of it
belongs to him
it belonged to him that car belonged to
him before you sold it agreed
right so
this is just a matter but you're saying
you feel like you want to transfer it
into a ministry somewhere and you feel
like that's the guidance that the holy
spirit's giving you i'm not going to
dispute that i'm really not
um that's a fine thing to do if you want
to do that and you're never gonna look
back and regret doing it you're never
gonna go oh that was the dumbest thing i
ever did in my life i've never said that
about generosity now i have given into
some situations where i didn't look into
it well or something like that and i
look back and i go well
probably should have been more careful
with that generosity i'm not sure i was
wise with it in terms of who i gave it
to or how i gave it or something like
that but i've never regretted the actual
act of giving
never once or obedience or the act of
following what i feel like is god's
voice okay
right so i understand the more you pray
about that then the more you get a peace
about you did hear god's voice on this
then the more you need to just do it
but it's not a finance it's not a
biblical financial principle
and it's not you know something that i
can tell you 100 this is
other than my sheep know my voice
follow the shepherd right
right
so have at it brother you're a good man
you got a tender good heart and you're
going to do well
you can never mess up being generous
well you can't but i mean it's you very
seldom regret it you never look back at
the end of your life and go man i just
gave too much
people never say that
it never comes up
they do say things like i really didn't
need some of those things i bought they
do say things like that
but the idea that
um we're gonna give that and i gotta
tell you when you got
four thousand dollars in credit card
debt and you got 2500 in your hand and
you're willing to release it
that says something about your spiritual
walk it absolutely does positive yeah
very positive very positive and you know
i i would say make this count you know
in the sense of you know this is an
investment you've been asked to give
so give it wisely if there's nothing
specific that you've been led to then
really do your homework and invest this
wisely because it's going to come back
yeah in multiple ways
but also jacob probably what you're
learning through this whole process is
to remember a hundred percent of it is
god's
and then he gives us guidelines on how
to manage his money for him
one of those guidelines is take care of
your own household first
or you're worse than an unbeliever
that's a scriptural guideline
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions and
jeremy and ashley are on the debt-free
stage congratulations guys where are
y'all from uh new philadelphia ohio cool
good to have you welcome to nashville
how much debt have you paid off uh 241
and 600 dollars good for you guys and
how long did that take
five years and six months wow and your
range of income during that time uh it
stayed pretty consistent around a
hundred thousand dollars we had a couple
medical events in there and a job change
cool what do y'all do for a living i am
a local truck driver
i'm an insurance sales agent very good
good for you guys fun so what kind of
debt is this 242 thousand three cars a
lawn mower our deck a 401k loan and our
house oh there goes the house
look at the weird people and the
lawnmower
yeah guys
[Laughter]
i love it not a debt in the world
congratulations fabulously done so how
old are you two i am 36 i'm 34. this is
the 30 year old debt free house and
everything show today yes wow 36 and 34.
very cool five years and six months
you've been pounding at this whole
process
uh as a as a insurance agent and a truck
driver very very well done what's the
house worth about 380 right now
very cool how much in your retirement
accounts a little over a hundred
thousand good for you all right so
you're up over half a million total give
or take and uh heading towards a million
dollars getting ready to be baby steps
millionaires look at you guys i'm so
proud of you 34 36 years old you're
kicking it well done all right so what
happened five years ago cause y'all are
weird we are weird
so
about five years ago
i work for a small manufacturing company
and the president of that company takes
like the growth of his employees very
seriously both personally and
professionally so
he shuts down the plant like six to
eight times every year and we have just
small group discussions about everything
you can imagine from leadership to life
to even finances wow so one day in 2016
the end of 2016 um the topic of the day
was a guy named dave ramsey and his
seven step process to financial freedom
so
i left the meeting a little intrigued
but
didn't really bounce on anything until a
couple days later the hr lady actually
sent out a mass email to everybody
saying that
she had a copy of your book if anybody
wanted to borrow it so of course i
jumped all over that borrowed it and
within
i don't know two weeks you guys had me
like hook line and sinker
wow
this is intriguing so how big a
manufacturing plan is that uh it's about
a hundred people okay so he just shut it
down had all the discussions uh
periodically to help his his men and
women there do better right it's during
our great leadership slow times but yeah
about eight times a year i gotta follow
up on that do you guys have low turnover
yes now that now let me tell you
something that that right there dave is
the example of investing in your people
manufacturing is a high turnover
business and you have low turnover how
much of it where you used to work can
you work there i know but my point is is
that low turnover that's a big big
takeaway there investment in people they
don't want to leave good for you man
that's great wow so uh that's fun and
they they'll you know go by pick up the
book the linda linda library thing here
and two weeks later uh so
actually jeremy's uh getting
indoctrinated at work um what were you
what were you saying at home i just
pretty much thought he was crazy and
i was like do what you want i'll do what
i want it's fine
and
then he made me sit down and do a budget
sheet of every little penny we spent for
a few months
and that's when i realized what we were
spending and where we were spending it
and that it was really time to make some
changes oh wake up call yes okay yeah
that's kind of revealing
a little shame inducing
but uh it's our conviction i guess is
better than shame you get convicted when
you look and you go where's all our
money going look at this well i know why
we don't have any retirement we're
eating it we eat out every night
that was nice that's what people that's
what happens when you look at this stuff
pretty cool guys and so game on after
that huh for sure all right and what did
you do following that you get on a
budget and you start following the baby
steps yep um we pretty much stayed
gazelle intense the whole time uh even
after bb step two when we paid off all
the debt um
we just kept throwing everything we
could at the mortgage like that was the
end goal we didn't feel debt free until
the mortgage was out from under us
because
when we signed the mortgage paper
the paperwork we felt like we was never
going to pay it off it was a hundred and
we ended up borrowing about two hundred
thousand dollars on the house
and it just felt like it was you know an
insurpassible mountain something we
would never
you know never climb felt like you
shined your life away right exactly
literally yes
but then you say no i'm taking my life
back correct way to go guys very very
cool congratulations thank you what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is now that you've done it
i would say the key would be to make
your budget follow your budget um there
was many times we wanted to go do
something but it wasn't in our budget or
we didn't have
the cash flow for it or we
you know we told friends and family we
couldn't go out to eat that month
because we already spent our monthly
budget and
just sticking to the budget it really
does work
i got a question about the momentum part
of this journey i mean this is a long
time five years six months that's a
journey is there a point where you hit
kind of okay uh we we feel like we're on
the downhill slope here we've got this
despite challenges budget issues saying
no was there a moment of great momentum
that you remember
probably like 2020 like right when covet
hit
um we didn't slow down we got busier and
made more you know was making more money
and the government kind of helped with a
little bit i guess and uh sure it just
made the process easier and it was like
look if we dial everything in right now
we can have this paid off by
you know
wow and we literally just paid it off
what a week and a half ago yes wow
we don't we don't have the first check
yet but
we already love it that is awesome
man so how's it feel to be a 100 free
amazing free i don't know that it's hit
me yet like i still i i don't know
i just the i mowed the i told her i
moved to grass the other day and
it felt a little different but
well think about that new budget you get
to do right coming up first tractor uh
oh there's there's they got the money
spent already so there's there we go yes
the kids
[Laughter]
didn't take long
didn't take long to adjust to the
newfound prosperity are you getting a
zero turn
no i have a steiner right now oh okay
all right all right here we go game on
we're talking tractor now
[Laughter]
well done you guys very very well done
who are your biggest cheerleaders
outside you guys
i would say his cousins um we're pretty
private people in life so not many
people know our you know financial
situation or what we're doing but his
cousins also follow dave ramsey so they
were
definitely on our journey with us we
were very open with them
we went out to dinner with them a lot
they would never let us even pay for our
dinner because they said take that money
and put it on your house there you go
that's awesome wow so priority number
one is paying for their meal yeah
there you go we're taking you to dinner
tonight right yeah
because we now can this is awesome
live like no one else later you can live
and buy your cousin's dinner
i was gonna say eat like no one else
there you go that's kind of nice
i'm going with that one i'm going with
that i'm sticking to it way to go guys
all right bring the kiddos up what are
their names and ages
oh we have easton he's seven
good
this is carson he's 11. riley's 13. jace
is eight and rylan is 12. all right very
cool well done guys very well done you
changed your family tree we got a copy
of baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story
you are well on your way probably by the
time you're 40 or so you're gonna be
there at this current rate well done
very well done
and also a copy of total money makeover
maybe you can loan it to somebody at
work you never know how that's gonna
turn out look what happened to you so
good stuff all right jeremy and ashley
and the gang 242 thousand dollars paid
off house and everything
five years and six months later making
100k count it down let's hear a debt
free scream all right three
two
one
we're debt-free
i love it all right jeremy you got to
call your old boss tell him you paid off
your house because of what he did at
that plant yes that's good stuff
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 147 4 and 5.
he determines the number of stars and
calls them by name
great is our lord and mighty in power
his understanding has no limit
oliver wendell holmes said the young man
knows the rules but the old man knows
the exceptions that's deep
that's so true
that would be true
ken coleman
dr john deloney george campbell rachel
cruz and i are doing a bel a building
wealth event
tomorrow evening thursday evening in las
vegas
if you want to come there are still a
few tickets left we've sold almost 3 000
tickets for the event wow we would love
to have you i just got an update a
minute ago it's 2625 tickets sold so far
and uh so there's still some tickets
available you still can come we would
love to have you las vegas uh may the
5th for those of you listening to this
at another time thursday night or is
going to be the event and um
they're at central church and just jump
online at ramsey solutions dot com
events you can pick up your tickets
they're only 25
you can get a four pack and you and your
spouse can bring some friends
for only sixty dollars and you get these
people you've been trying to talk into
this stuff uh this is a good uh way of
learning because we're going to be
talking about a lot of the things
happening in the culture right now ken
and dr dalone are going to be doing a
breakout ahead of time
and
a kickoff thing and then we'll be doing
the major event with all of us and be
signing books and pictures and
everything afterwards um it is a full-on
ramsey ramsey personalities event of
course i'll be there in the midst of all
of it as well so make sure you're coming
out las vegas may the 5th tomorrow night
thursday night still some tickets again
only 25 and there's still some left
about 3 000 folks going to be there so
by the way that means if you've got a
ticket you should get there pretty early
because
it takes a little while to move 3000
people in and out of a building it's not
an instantaneous process if you thought
oh it's just dave and ken i'm gonna go
hang out with them well yeah no no takes
a little bit so give yourself a little
give yourself a little margin it's a
thursday night work night so uh school
night so you know give yourself a little
margin and make sure you get over there
it's gonna be fun ken i you know we're
so glad to be back out on the road it's
one of the the really the key tenets of
what we do at ramsey solutions and
meeting people where they are and
getting out on the road and of course we
just all missed it you know we missed
the energy our events are always a lot
of fun we like people we do it's not
good that man be alone no and there's
something special about a room dave
where people are there to get better
whatever the topic you know and these
are people that are intentional that
come to these events and
and uh i can tell you times i have sat
in an audience yeah in various you know
sales conferences
uh
seminars of different kinds church
where i'm sitting in the audience and
something done and said from stage and
i'm in proximity to thousands of other
humans
and it feels like right that moment that
something happened and that turned the
trajectory in my life
yeah it's gonna be fun can't wait come
on out and we're just getting started we
we got more events coming uh we got a
full fall slate too so orlando may 19th
as well coming to our last two weeks
we'll be in orlando so go and get that
go and get those tickets and we got
about the same number of tickets sold
there as well so good stuff all right
bob is in eugene oregon hey bob how are
you
hello how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
um so i'm an electrical contractor and
i'm new i've only been
i've been doing it for 18 years but
business for three
and i'd like to branch out but i don't
know exactly
how much money i should have reserved to
hire an employee
i gotta in the work i'm kind of sketchy
on the work too i mean i got two weeks
booked out to three months it varies
as as the time goes on and i just what's
the
good amount of money i should have set
aside to hire an employee
okay are you running a profit loss
statement on your
business yeah
okay how much profit do you make a month
oh uh i
we're not the most thorough we do that i
can tell you at the end of the year what
my profit is okay you start doing one
monthly
okay and uh because that'll give you
uh what you're really making on the
business that month and then the same
time next year you'll look and say okay
i'm doing better or worse than last year
and that kind of thing starts to give
you some measures in the business to
know where you're going and how you're
doing it
um so what did you pay taxes on last
year
100 000 way to go good for you what does
it cost to hire someone
for base
for a journeyman in our area about 60
000. okay
all right and so if you add no revenue
to your company
as a result of hiring him you'll make
40.
yeah okay but he gets paid
can you do that
if you
you think you're going to get more you
think you're going to get some more work
right
yeah yeah
i'm hoping to get an employee so then i
can push for going to try and fetch more
to work instead of doing
the whole rig overall
but you've the net result has to be that
the company has takes in
more than 60 000
more than it used to right
yeah that's the scary part for me
and you kind of you kind of got to
figure that out okay i'm making this per
job and this is what you know how many
jobs can i add if i'm doing something
he's doing something i'm out there
you know snagging new work and you're
figuring that out because all of that
factors into how much you should have
set aside because if if you can bring in
enough to pay for them from day one then
obviously you would not need to set
aside anything
but if you but if it's gonna take you
three months to get ramped up once they
come on board then you need fifteen
thousand dollars because that's three
months of sixty thousand a year or five
thousand a month
okay kind of look at that so you know
it'd be a good idea to have an extra 10
grand laying around
um the economy also i'd well the the
status of the world has me i i'm a
little bit too paranoid on that i
probably shouldn't be well yeah let me
speak to that for a second bob because i
don't know if you know this or not i'm
sure you do but
we saw the trades explode in 2020
in 2021 and in 2020 we thought the world
was coming to an end nobody knew what
the economy was going to do and the
trades never missed a beat it turned out
you were essential yeah so yeah so i i i
appreciate a healthy amount of caution
but i i would uh guard against fear yeah
yeah i i think you give it a shot dude
and you just be honest with the guy
that's coming in go i never done this
before i'm a little bit scared but i
think i got a lot of work here and if
you want to try this together with me
let's do it and that's how i heard my
first person i told him the truth
marisa is with us in phoenix hi marisa
what's up
hi i'm grateful to be here thank you for
taking my call sure how can we help
i am engaged and um something that i'd
like before the wedding is
for my fiance to get out of credit cards
debt good what's he made just recent
uh makes about a hundred thousand a year
how much is his credit card debt
thirty five thousand has he got any
money
a little bit of an emergency savings how
much
a thousand dollars okay you got baby
step one okay
and uh when are you planning on getting
married
no date set because it's important to me
that we can tackle this um credit card
debt no we don't tackle credit card debt
when we aren't married he tackles credit
card debt
yes you don't pay his debt until you're
married he pays it
got it that's clear yeah that that's
going to create a strain on the
relationship and a major mess in the
event of a breakup
and no you don't want to do any of that
it's not good for anybody involved so
now and i i you can do what you want to
do we at ramsey
don't tell people to avoid marriage
because of debt we do tell people to
avoid marriage
because someone doesn't want to deal
with their debt but if your fiance is
plowing into this and is aggressively
attacking it using the debt snowball
living on a budget being careful being
wise being frugal and hitting this debt
hard and he's knocked off 10 000 of the
30 000 and you can see that he's well on
his way and he's a changed man and the
credit cards are cut up
then i i wouldn't as my if you were my
daughter i would tell you to marry him
and that's what i'm working working
towards but um he recently talked to me
about him taking out a personal loan
or some options in consolidating his
credit card debt which leads me to
calling you because he finally gave me
that green light where he's ready
to move forward so you don't need to
consolidate anything you just need to
pay it it makes 100 000 a year he can
pay it really really fast he hasn't got
any expenses except you right now and
you could be determined to not be an
expense starting ready set go
yeah uh what we need to do is we'll get
you guys into financial peace university
hold on kelly i'll sign you guys up
we'll give it to you as an advanced
wedding gift
and you guys go through it and start
talking about it but he pays his own
debt and he starts on it immediately and
we don't borrow our way out of debt with
consolidation that puts us hour the
ramsey show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christchurch the ramsay show is
one of the most popular podcasts in the
world it's your daily dose of advice on
life and money check out all of our
shows from the ramsey network wherever
you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you